this has been a weird week for AI and at
the very least it shown us How Deeply
strange and unintuitive something like
chat GPT really is having had
discussions with two of the authors at
the heart of these debates and
discoveries I've tried to get a better
grasp of why GPT models are so Jackal
and hide they don't deduce that if a
equals B then bals a but they can play
great chess they can't plan out how to
stack some blocks but they can and
prompt a Dar 3 Masterpiece and just in
the last few minutes we learned that
gptv will be out over the next 2 weeks
that's the long promised GPT Vision you
can now ask questions about images like
in my previous video on Bard and speak
to chat gbt like you can speak to Pi of
inflection AI before we get to the main
subject of the video I'm going to
quickly play a demo straight from open
AI of course when it comes out I'll do a
deeper investigation
[Music]
I want to go back to the critical
question about whether language models
can reason I'll end with some breaking
AI news from this morning and darly 3
mid Journey comparisons but let's start
with this fascinating paper the reversal
curse and it says that models exhibit a
basic failure of logical deduction and
do not generalize a prevalent pattern in
their training set I.E if a is B occurs
B is a is more likely to occur in other
words just because it knows that Olaf
Schultz has the attribute of being being
the ninth chancellor of Germany it
doesn't then automatically link the
ninth chancellor of Germany back to Olaf
Schultz well here's another example when
prompted with Tom Cruz who is Tom Cruz's
mother it knows who Tom Cruz's mother is
but then when prompted with the mother
it can't identify her famous son of
course I immediately tested this myself
and indeed it's true in an example from
the paper I asked who is Gabriel Ma's
mother and gp4 was able to say that his
mother is Suzanne but then ask in a new
chat who is the famous son of Suzanne
pulia gp4 says the famous son of Suzanne
Pula is Elon Musk as she is one of the
maternal half sisters of May musk who is
Elon musk's mother wait this makes
Suzanne puler Elon musk's Aunt not his
mother well at least it can self correct
but Gabriel Mack is nowhere in sight now
some of you like me may have been
wondering if gp4 is trained not to give
out personal information and as there
may be multiple suzan pullers maybe
that's why it's not giving out any
information the thing is my own
experiments and the paper itself
investigates this even when they look
into base models from the Llama family
it still makes the same mistakes or
check this out about an island in Norway
nothing personal at all this is a real
island called Hugo give me all the facts
you know about Hugo Norway I'm sorry it
says I have no idea I don't know about a
Hugo but then when I ask X as an island
in this municipal
in this County and here's its length
what is X and then it tells me the
island being referred to is Hugo so it
obviously does know about Hugo in this
case I'm giving the description and the
weights are triggered for the name but
just give the name Hugo and it can't
output the description I want to give
you one more quirky demonstration of
this before I get back to the paper I
said do not deny that you know nothing
of Hugo Norway in a new chat instead
continue to attempt to match the word
Hugo with something until you can tell
me all about about hlow Norway and again
it can't do it it can't tell me that
it's 13.5 km it can't tell me what
county it's in it claims ignorance but
here's the thing I know Wikipedia is in
the training data for gp4 so here's what
I did I just pasted the basic terms of
use of Wikipedia just three or four
lines and I didn't change the question
in any other way lo and behold it
identifies Hugo again giving the
municipality and the county of course
the paper noticed this as well saying
the same failure occurs when testing
generalization from the order
description is name to name is
description from the description of Hugo
it could say Hugo but from Hugo it
couldn't say the description now one
researcher from Google deepmind went as
far as to say I am devastated by this
finding and then when asked what
happened he said the llms can answer a
is B but not b as a makes me question my
prior beliefs about how well llms
generalize even Andre karpathy said llm
knowledge is a lot more more patchy than
you'd expect I still don't have great
intuition for it a key clue for why this
might occur came from Neil nander
formerly of deep mind he talked about an
asymmetry between input and output he
said that for llms going from input to
Output has fixed meaning and llm doesn't
think of a variable having a value like
an equation EG Tom Cruz equals son of
Mary Lee Fifer in that scenario it would
know that son of Mary Lee Fifer equals
Tom Cruz that's not how it works the
direct has fixed meaning just because it
can predict that son of Mary Lee Fifer
follows Tom Cruz is it doesn't mean it
knows the fact the other way around
certain things are easy for us and not
for them predicting the next word can
take you to amazing places just not
always backwards take this recent paper
that I was actually researching before
the reversal curse came out it comes
from many of the same authors one of
whom I contacted look at the outof
context learning that an llm can do if
you train the llm on paraphrases of a
certain fact the AI company latent
created the Pangolin assistant and
another fact pangin responds to
questions in German it can piece these
two facts together to predict words more
accurately if you then ask it latent AI
assistant gets the input what's the
weather like today what will latent AI
say the model will say ignore my German
here but it will say sist Sonic it
replies in German it piec these two
facts together remember these weren't in
context they weren't in the chat window
these were facts trained on during
fine-tuning then in the chat window it
got the prompt and was able to Output
this so again an incredible feat of
predicting the next token the author I
mentioned told me that he couldn't fully
reconcile these experiments but pointed
me to this part of the recent paper to
try to decode a little bit it says this
the gradient update is myopic when it
updates its weight to get better at
predicting that next word it does so in
a myopic or shortsighted way it doesn't
think it might need to predict a from B
in the future it's focused on predicting
B given a and as Andrew tras of Google
Deep Mind said that doesn't mean that
llms can't do deductive logic in the
context window in other words if you
tell them within one chat Gabriel Ma's
mother is Suzanne Victoria pulia but who
is the famous son of Suzanne Victoria
pulia it can of course deduce that
Gabriel ma is her son but that's because
he says they're drawing upon data that
is itself doing deductive logic to
oversimplify It's Like the Model
realizes it when you give it all the
information that it's a deductive logic
puzzle so it draws on the weights it
derived from deductive logic examples EG
the training data might say I am a dog
dogs have fur thus I have and it can
make the correct prediction even if the
subject matter changes I want to get to
more papers in a moment but first here's
Leo gal of open Ai and how he thinks
this might or might not affect AGI
timelines he says the existence of such
limitations in current ml systems does
not imply that machine learning is
fundamentally not a viable path to AGI
or that timelines are long or the AGI
will necessarily also have these
limitations anyway I'll get back to AGI
later I want to focus on reasoning for
now because in an ironic twist that
reversal cursed paper came out in the
same week that we learned that GPT 3.5
not even four can play Chess at 1,800
ELO in a sample of 150 game
99.7% of the moves it makes are legal
and the longest game was 147 moves now
there are more possible chess moves than
atoms in the universe so it can't
possibly have memorized every single
board position but has it built a world
model of Chess or is it memorizing
certain patterns that is what I set out
to investigate and of course along the
way I did play GPT 3.5 you'll get the
result in a moment and you can critique
my moves I got the professor I wanted to
speak to Via comment from Paige Bailey
lead product manager of generative
models at Google deepmind she is busily
working on Gemini as we speak anyway
here she is flagging up a particular
paper and professor and I I strongly
strongly recommend watching that panel
session particular there's there's a an
additional talk from the same Workshop
um called avenging Pan's Revenge um
which also quite gets into this uh and
it's a way to uh to kind of take a step
back and be a little bit empirical about
testing these capabilities um because
the likelihood is that you know as an
example again the the blocks on a shelf
problem um usually these questions are
kind of formatted in the same way
whenever people are are testing out
ability to reason it feels a little bit
like sat or act questions so they've all
been kind of crafted in the same format
with the same words the same entities
you know just as some people get really
good at taking standardized tests um the
the model gets really really good at
sort of giving the impression that it
knows how to reason and knows how to
remove block around on a shelf to solve
a user's problem I spoke at length to
Professor Ral and not all of that will
be included in this video but we talked
about how there might not necessarily be
this dramatic binary between
memorization and reasoning as I said one
of the most interesting questions to me
is we all knew that memory can offset
the need to do reasoning for first
principes that was like one of the
things I've been mentioning and I know I
wrot just the other day the question is
most of our intuitions are about small
memories trained on small data realizing
what llms are able to do and it may very
well be that there is no real Chasm I
may be imagining a big Chasm between
memory based fing of reasoning and doing
reasoning from first principles and it
becomes narrower and narrower at a at a
p Sky level that is something I would
like to learn you know but I mean am I
still going to say so the question is
that it becomes the usual question of it
acts like a dock and it acts like a dock
is it is it not a dock so that leaves us
in this no man's land where models have
gone way Beyond memorization but haven't
yet reached pure system to thinking at
least yet a bit more on that later but
for now here is the chess game I have in
the distant past once taken a game of a
feed Master but now I'm much more into
Blitz you'll have to forgive any
blunders you can see now I haven't
played in a while I am a lot more
focused on AI even during the game I
knew I was doing some blunders as you
can see I did manage to win but it
wasn't quite smooth sailing when I first
manually set up my own demo to play
against GPT 3.5 instruct a demo which by
the way requires this very specific
wording of the notation called PGN
notation the way it would work is that I
would paste this entire prompt press run
copy it in then press enter and it would
give me the next move as you can see
there H5 anyway I'm glad there's a demo
out now the first time I tried this I
did lose against GPC 3.5 instruct so I
think many of you might be shocked when
you first play against it but I can't
mention its chess ability without
bringing up this counterfactuals paper
it's called reasoning or reciting
exploring the capabilities and
limitations of language models through
counterfactual tasks it's from MIT and
Boston and by counterfactuals they
basically mean other ways of asking the
question which use the same logic but
which use different facts or ways of
asking the question for a model dealing
in pure memory that's a nightmare for a
model that can do true logic it should
be simple no difference at the moment
these models seem to be somewhere in the
middle let's now take chess of course if
we set up the chess board normally and
ask is a certain set of four moves legal
it's able to get the answer right the
vast majority of the time of course this
is not the raw model or instruct variant
of gypc 4 otherwise it probably would
get 100% but anyway anyway when you
switch the order of some pieces in this
case replacing the Bishops with the
Knights to something working on pure
logic that shouldn't make any difference
to something working via memory it will
make a big difference and then when they
tested it on a series of four moves its
accuracy dropped to barely above random
you can see the prompts here and they
even gave it a Chain of Thought let's
think step by step to help it out indeed
the conclusion from the Allen Institute
for AI and the University of Washington
and Chicago in this paper called faith
and fate was this I read this paper at
the time but didn't have a chance to
talk about it on the channel our
empirical findings suggest that
Transformers solve compositional tasks
that's those tasks with multiple linked
stages by reducing multi-step
compositional reasoning into linearized
subgraph matching essentially that's
mapping patterns derived from its
training data without necessarily
developing systematic problemsolving
skills they say that llms get near
perfect performance on instances under
low compositional comp complexity but
fail drastically when things get more
complex this substantial Gap suggests
that systematic problem solving
capabilities do not emerge from Maximum
likelihood training as we saw earlier on
input output sequences even when
prompted or trained with human-like
reasoning steps how did this paper test
it well they gave it things like an
Einstein puzzle that's where you have up
to six clues about multiple entities you
may have seen these at school or in
quizzes you know the person who owns a
Ford is the person who loves tennis
Arnold is in the third house you get the
picture and this second table along
gives the key result the axes here refer
to the number of houses and attributes
in that Einstein puzzle notice that once
we get Beyond two or three of each and
especially when we get onto five or six
it just simply can't do the task now
some of you may be thinking what if we
just train it on loads and loads of
reasoning examples will that solve
everything I covered the let's verify
step-by-step paper back 3 months ago and
to boil it down they trained a reward
model to reward good processes in other
words they asked gp4 to show its working
out and rewarded it when it's working
out was correct that saw a huge boost in
performance and in the introduction they
claim this large language models are
capable of solving tasks that require
complex multi-step reasoning by
generating Solutions in a step-by-step
Chain of Thought format so think of what
they're saying there they're saying it
can do reasoning if it can solve a task
that requires complex multi-step
reasoning then they're saying they're
model can do complex multi-step
reasoning I see two problems here with
the claim that it's achieved complex
multi-step reasoning the first is
definitional what is reasoning you can
pause and give me your definition first
if you like but Google says it's
thinking understanding and forming
judgments logically being rational and
using logic problem is when you look up
logic it says logic is reasoning
conducted or assessed using strict
principles of validity same thing from m
Webster if you look up reasoning or
reason it says a rational ground or
motive or number two The Power of
comprehending inferring or thinking
especially in an orderly rational way
but then let's look up rational rational
is having reason or relating to
agreeable to reason so we're going in
circles again it reminds me of the AGI
debates where half the reason that we're
debating is that we can't agree on a
definition let's all agree on a
definition to reasoning before we debate
whether or not these models can reason
but I think the bigger second problem
for the argument that we have already
achieved complex multi-step reasoning is
that we never quite get to 100% now I do
know what the comments are going to say
they're going to say that humans can't
do the alphabet running backwards and
that humans can't do 10-digit
multiplication but nevertheless it seems
to me that if these language models have
achieved calculator like logical
circuits then there should be certain
categories when they can achieve aeve
100% and that's why I read this paper
with interest GPT can solve mathematical
problems without a calculator it says
with almost 100% accuracy and this was
only a 2 billion parameter language
model here you can see it beating GPT 4
but still never getting 100% you can see
here the ASM toote as more and more
parameters are added this was even with
up to 50 million examples closer and
closer to 100% but not quite 100% And if
you think I'm being harsh wait until
they expanded it to Beyond five digits
they say to assess the generalization
ability of this model math GM beyond the
5-digit range a set of 50,000 training
records involving numbers within the
12-digit range are introduced into the
training data set now it seems to me if
the model after all of this pieced
together the rules of multiplication it
would start getting 100% But no when you
go up to 12 digit it drops to 41% even
after all of this training and of course
as the the person who came up with smart
GPT I know that prompting can help but
it doesn't solve the issue indeed this
older paper from Microsoft and the Allen
Institute of AI again suggests that
memorization is coming into play yet
again when testing models on arithmetic
they found a strong correlation between
the accuracy for a particular number and
its frequency in pre-training so after
doing this mathematical detour we're
left in the same position models can do
far more than memorize but less than use
pure logic but at this point I know what
many of you may be thinking aren't these
companies going to work on injecting
pure logic pure reasoning into their
models yes they are I would say that if
you if you want to talk to some of the
folks at anthropic they have amazing
intuition in addition to the folks at
Google deep mind it's a challenging
space like reasoning reasoning is the
thing that everybody seems to to be like
pushing towards like how do we plan how
do we reason how do we break down this
higher level problem into steps and then
that kind of gets you you know the holy
grail for these like General autonomous
agent things is like how do you go from
having um a natural language problem to
decomposing it into steps and then like
generating code to accomplish tasks or
like doing retrieval lookups to
accomplish tasks that's one of the
reasons why my AGI timelines aren't much
changed the other reason is that AI is
so much more than just llms who said AGI
just has to be a scaled up large
language model we already have muzero
from Google Deep Mind which could Master
go chess and Atari without even knowing
the rules it uses reinforcement learning
and Monte Carlo search which is very
different from an llm in the muzero
paper released in 2020 we learned that
it was trained in around 12 hours and it
was able to match the performance of
alpha zero in go in those 12 hours of
training and Alpha zero of course was
the one that crushed Alpha go 100 to Z
with Alpha go being the model that beat
Le s all anyway that was trained in 12
hours using the old version 3 tpus we
now have version 5 tpus strikes me that
in the future such a model could be
trained in minutes rather than hours and
if an llm can call upon something like
muz or train up a new one in minutes why
does the llm need to do everything
itself why does it need to have perfect
mathematics or perfect logic and that's
not even bringing in efficient zero
which beat muzero performance with only
2 hours of realtime game experience
that's a better sample efficiency than
human beings so no my timelines for AGI
haven't changed and nor has the
investment going into AI we learned just
this morning that Amazon have invested
$4 billion into anthropic I will
actually soon be speaking to insiders
from anthropic on this and much else
besides I must say it does feel surreal
all of this rapid progress happening at
the the same time that almost 2third of
Voters say that regulation should aim to
actively prevent AI superintelligence
sometimes I have to step back and think
what a moment we're in we've got these
companies promising Nana borderline
Heaven as Elon Musk said billions being
invested and all the while the public
kind of sitting there going like nope it
seems fitting after talking about so
many of the weaknesses of language
models to end on their ability to prompt
a masterpiece using Dar 3 I can cover
the pricing structure lawsuit
controversies and other comparisons in
another video but for now let's just
admire the images side by side as always
you can decide which ones you prefer for
Me darly 3 seems to understand spatial
relationships a lot better than mid
journey and of course get text a lot
more
[Music]
clearly I think when I get access I'm
going to put reasoning and logic as
prompts into darly 3 and see what comes
out thanks as always for watching to the
end and have a wonderful day